there's a snake out there that's a  nightmare to other snakes the king cobra  king cobras have a very specialized diet  they eat other snakes  king cobras are very big snakes your  average size is about eight to ten feet  in length the largest of the king cobras  get to about 18 feet  [Music]  and they're also very slender they're  very quick on the ground so there's very  few other snakes that came out slither  king cobra its venom is a pure  neurotoxin it basically kills by  asphyxiation it brings a complete  shutdown of the nervous system and  breathing collapses and that's when the  king cobra goes in and then eat it  sometimes they're cannibals where they  eat another king cobra  there are other states that have also  been documented eating other snakes but  in terms of like being a specialized  snake eater the king cobra takes the top  spot so if you're a person that doesn't  like snakes  well you have good reason to like a king  cobra because it eats other snakes  [Music]  Oh